تنضم الينا من تل ابيب مراسله الجزيره
نجوان سمري مرحبا بك نجوان قربينا اكثر من
سياق كل هذه الاحداث
والمواقف نعم بخصوص اليوم التالي في غزه
يتواصل انعقاد للمجلس الوزاري الامني
والسياسي في اسرائيل حاليا في وزاره
الدفاع في تل ابيب من اجل بحث ما
نسب ايضا او تسرب عن وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يوف جلان قبل بدء هذا الاجتماع
بالتصور التي وضعته القياده الامنيه
والعسكريه لهذه المرحله ما بعد الحرب في
غزه وهو يتحدث عن ان اسرائيل اولا لن
تتولى الشؤون الام الاداريه او المدنيه في
غزه ما بعد الحرب وانما قال بان من وصفهم
بالفلسطينيين الذين لا يبدون عداء
لاسرائيل هم من سيقومون اي بذلك هذا على
مستوى اداره الشؤون المدنيه ولكنه اكد بان
اسرائيل
ستواصل السيطره الامنيه على قطاع غزه بشكل
او باخر وستكون هناك عمليات عسكريه دون
قيد او شرط هذا وفقا ما تم نقله عن وزير
الدفاع يوف جلاند قبيل بدء هذا الاجتماع
ووفقا لوسائل اعلام اسرائيليه فان هذا
التصور يشمل ايضا تقسيم مهام ربما بين
الاشراف الامني الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه
وبين مشاركه ايضا القاهره ومصر في بعض
الامور الامنيه
منها محور فيلادلفيا وهي الحدود التي تفصل
بين مصر وغزه لكن يبدو بان اسرائيل تطالب
ان يكون لها دور ايضا في السيطره الامنيه
على هذا المحور وهناك من ستوكل اليهم مهمه
اعاده الاعمار بالتعاون مع دول اوروبيه
ومع دول اخرى في المنطقه بالاضافه الى دور
اخر سيكون للولايات المتحده ايضا في عده
نقاط لكن مره اخرى هذا التصور الاولي
للقياده الامنيه في اسرائيل للمستوى
الامني في اسرائيل وهذا ما سيبحث الليله
في هذا الاجتماع لكن حتى الان لا يوجد
فكره واحده هناك عده سيناريوهات هناك عده
اجتماعات امنيه اجريت في الاسبوع الاخير
لا سما تلك التي عقدها وزير الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه روني دريمر في واشنطن وايضا
القياده العسكريه وسيتم طرح كل هذه الخطط
والمقترحات على طاوله الاجتماع المج
المجلس الوزاري المصغر هذه الليله ومن غير
الواضح فيما اذا كان سيصدر بعدها اي توجه
سيتخذه وفق قرار سيتخذه هذا المجلس لاي
خطه او سيناريو تتجه الامور في غزه لان
هذا المجلس هذه هي المره الاولى عمليا
الذي يبحث فيها هذا الموضوع بهذا الشكل
الموسع على مستوى المجلس الوزاري المصغر
قبل هذا الاجتماع عقد ايضا اجتماع لمجم
الحرب الضيق وتحدثت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
تحديدا القناه الثانيه ع عن خلافات بين
نتنياهو وبين جلنت هذه الخلافات تظهر ليست
للمره الاولى ولكن من الواضح انها اخذه في
التعمق في محاور ونقاط مختلفه بدات من منع
نتنياهو او لما صدر من معلومات عن منع
نتنياهو لوزير الدفاع بالتقاء كل من رئيسي
المساد والشباك على
دون وجود نتنياهو في هذه الاجتماعات والان
يبدو بانها اخذه بالتطور لانه نقل عن
جالنت عفوا بانه قال لنتنياهو في
محادثه محتدمه بينهما بانه يلحق الضرر في
امن اسرائيل مع منعه لمثل هذه اللقاءات
التي كانت تتعلق بالتقدم باتجاه ابرام
صفقه تبادل السي اشكرك نجوان سمري
مراسلتنا من تل ابيب